la jornada de este miércoles se cerró
aquí en tokio 2020 con la final de los
200 metros planos y fue el canadiense on
red de gas quien se impuso con un tiempo
de 19 segundos 62 centésimas por delante
de dos estadounidenses kenny werner aquí
y el número uno del mundo campeón
mundial no a rayos también se disputaron
las primeras cinco pruebas del decatlón
y por ahora es damián werner de canadá a
quien está liderando a veces una prueba
en las que hay muchas esperanzas de
medalla para francia que vine ayer quien
había se había llevado la medalla de
plata en río por ahora va como quinto
vamos a ver cómo le va al francés el día
de mañana cuando se haga en el resto de
pruebas porque ha sufrido mucho en un
momento una entrevista que concedió
justamente después de las primeras
pruebas esta mañana dijo que tenía un
dolor muy fuerte en la parte baja de la
espalda lo dijo prácticamente en
lágrimas pero ya ahorita está en la
noche en el asalto de altura le fue
bastante bien así que vamos a ver cómo
le va a las frases y bueno una de las
finales más esperadas muy atentos en
latinoamericana
américa y en colombia al final de los
400 metros lisos porque anthony zambrano
correr a esa final en la noche de este
jueves aquí en tokio